[Music]
welcome back to Hannity as we continue
with former White House chief strategist
Steve Bennett is with us
you know I go over this whole thing now
we know that Hilary basically rigged
install a primary there's no the
evidence is in overwhelming
incontrovertible then she tried to by
spending money we know she spent the
money she controlled the DNC they spent
the money and they pay for this phony
Russian dossier Russian lies propaganda
to influence the American people bought
and paid for by Clinton then we've got
this whole issue of uranium one Muller
knew in 2009 about and so did Eric
Holder about bribery extortion kickbacks
money laundering and we racketeering a
year later the uranium one deal goes
through Steve we have to import uranium
because we don't have enough uranium in
this country you can't no one has ever
given any simple why would we ever
knowing especially the crimes committed
by putin's thugs in this country ever
allow Putin control of 20% of our
uranium and they're not even talking
about the Clintons getting more money
and speaking fees and 145 million
kickback to the foundation when you look
at these things in light of what is
going on for a year when there's no
evidence of Trump Russia collusion as
Dianne Feinstein said on Sunday what are
your thoughts I think what you're seeing
is that the opposition party media the
progressive left Democrats and the
corporatists of trying to they're trying
to nullify the 2016 election is very
obvious what's going on I'm here in
Macomb County Michigan which is the home
of the Reagan Democrats that gave
President Trump an overwhelming victory
on election night and actually had the
Detroit Free Press reversed their call
of the state of Michigan for Hillary
Clinton and give it later to Donald
Trump in the working men and women of
this county are the ones that did it
and what you're seeing is that the
elites in this country don't want the
people in Macomb County to have a voice
they are trying to nullify the 2016
election and they're doing of every
underhanded thing to hit that's why this
the entire Russian collusion thing is a
joke it's been so much TV there was
collusion Hillary Clinton paid bought
and paid for Russian lies right
it was good clues he was whatever
termini it's incumbent I tell you that's
it that's incumbent to me upon Grassley
in the committee and also Senator
sessions if molar won't pick this up in
his investigation when he's now looking
at guys tax returns like Paul Manafort
sand and charges a wire fraud and things
that happened ten years ago then it
seems to me that Senator sessions has to
look into the to the Clinton situation
particularly uranium one I think a
Special Counsel ought to be designate
for uranium one the American of the
emails are the bottom of that there's
crimes on listen there's crimes on the
email server no crimes cover-up
obstruction espionage yeah all of these
things we've gone through I won't repeat
him but you're right twenty percent of
uranium really and Muller knew how could
he investigate anything Russia let me
ask you a political question yes and I
know this is important because you have
said you were going after those people
look we see people like Ben Sasse and
Jeff Flake and John McCain and other
people they hate the president they
haven't gotten a single thing
accomplished to the credit of the house
the house did pass almost three hundred
bills including you know sanctuary
cities and Kate's law they got some work
done and they passed a health care bill
imperfect but they got it done and my
question is is this isn't it at the end
of the day you and Reince Priebus rights
is more establishment than you you're
you're a conservative outside our kind
of like I think we agree on a lot of
politics so you're wrong on not cutting
taxes for everybody that's another at
night but you guys made it work why
can't the Republicans that maybe don't
like Trump personally look at his agenda
and say I asked them what part of his
agenda beyond beyond say trade that
isn't conservative there's coarsest
dollar conservative is his tax plan
except for the not across the board not
conservative immigration not
conservative listen this is what I gave
the speech about tonight about victory
about winning more victories in the
future rights and I came together as
soon as I was designated CEO of the of
the campaign the only way we won in the
85 days we had to go was to put together
a coalition you know we had the
religious right we had the tea party
groups and we had the populist we had
the economic nationalists and we had the
Republican establishment and rights and
I had a great working relationship we
had a great working relationship in the
in the white house I think what you're
saying is really the donor class and
particularly in the United States Senate
with with Mitch McConnell you know the
house is actually voted on 100 I think
it's 180 bills that the Senate has not
taken up including many bills would be a
very difficult vote for joe Manchin and
Claire McCaskill and John tester and
Heidi Heitkamp and other these red state
Democrats that we need to take down in
2018 in Mitch McConnell's refused to do
it tayshaun I'm to the point that I
think Mitch McConnell to really bring
unity to the Republican Party and get
things done I think Mitch McConnell
ought to tender his resignation what he
ought to do is offer to resign as soon
as taxes are done we can't do in the
middle of taxes but I think Mitch
McConnell tomorrow should tender his
resignation said hey after we get taxes
done I will step aside and we'll have a
revote on Majority Leader because I got
to tell you there needs to be a sense of
urgency in the Senate you know over the
last about week that you know they're
now going to work six days a week
they're talking about canceling
Thanksgiving they passed the budget
they're starting to move on federal
judges but that's all because quite
frankly we put the spotlight on Mitch
McConnell and said that this guy is just
not supporting the president and he's
not supporting the president the
president needs to drain the swamp he's
not helping the Forgotten men and women
the people in this country and activity
their lack of urgency there are many
vacations it's not hell the president
just by getting rid of burdensome Obama
era regulations look what's happened to
the economy imagine if they would
explode the economy with this bill it's
but they have given up on on Reagan
supply-side conservative tax cuts across
the board regular them from 70 to 28
percent top marginal rates this is
actually a private issue you and I
disagree with on that part they're great
on the corporate tax cuts the great on
the repatriation president's been great
on energy independence that all
stimulates the economy manufacturing
factories have gonna be built as a
result well I said look I think that
there's a this tax package is not
perfect I really don't think it's
fundamental tax reform yeah I think
we're gonna wait on that I think what
we're looking now is a tax cut let's get
this tax cut through look president
Trump's policies on economic nationalism
have the economy growing at over three
percent right now
all the geniuses right on MSNBC and CNN
The Wall Street Journal they never
thought that President Trump would get
to three percent on his economic
nationalism he has the lowest Hispanic
what unemployment rate in eleven years
of lost black unemployment in seventeen
years wages are starting to rise look
among the working class and construction
and agriculture we there's more business
investment yeah because his program is
working his program of saying hey I'm
gonna have tariffs I'm gonna have quotas
unless you start a factories in the
United States is working I agree with
you a McConnell step-up get the job done
or get out I'm tired of it Steve good he
should he should tell you he's your
tenders resignation tonight for after
the tax cuts I know you're here you
doing interviews we appreciate you
coming on the program thank you